is that the first man you've killed the
first man next time you're going to do
something like that tell me first hey
youtubers welcome to part 2 of my many
parts Game of Thrones season 4 preview
video I'd like to say it's gonna be
three parts but I could talk about A
Song of Ice and Fire all day so we'll
see how it goes in case you didn't see
my part 1 video I'm separating these by
geographic region relatively there are a
lot of people that wander in a game of
Thrones this video will deal with the
characters in the north and around the
wall notably Jon Snow and said wanderer
Arya Stark there will be some spoilers
so I'll try to let you know in advance
just in case you need to mute the audio
for a minute but you will have to wait
till next January to find out so I would
advise you to listen to them so we can
all geeked out together talking about
Game of Thrones is so much more fun when
everyone's on the same page so shall we
begin let's talk about Jon Snow first
not only is he a main character in the
books Kit Harington the actor has
actually gotten more and more scenes and
more lines as the show has gone on he's
actually listed in the opening credits
as one of the first couple actors in
those spots are usually reserved for
major stars that's not to say that he is
one of the most important characters in
the books obviously he's a fan favorite
but I feel like when the show's
producers put him in more scenes they're
actually trying to tell us that he's one
of the most important characters on the
show so if you thought Jon Snow was
gonna be big in season 3 he's actually
gonna be even bigger in season 4
remember at the end of season 3 he
actually just made it back to the Nights
Watch after going through what I like to
call a wildling breakup pretty normal
for them I imagine just think in real
life what it might have been like you
grid comes up to him and says hey we can
either talk about our relationship all
night and where we're going where we're
heading or I can shoot you with three
arrows and we'll be broken up Jon Snow
sits there and thinks for a minute
mm I'll take the arrows don't snow is
not much for long conversations let's
get into spoiler territory I'll try to
be as vague as possible if you're
someone who likes to do a lot of
internet sleuthing or you just want to
read the books again like I said Jon
Snow's gonna spend most of his time at
the wall in season 4 obviously the
events will cover most of the rest of
book 3 and parts of book 4 so I'm not
really sure what the book 4 parts are
going to be in the show but that might
happen later in the season there will be
one returning
character coming back to the Nights
Watch that we haven't seen in a while
Janos Slynt is actually the character
that tyrion fired as head of the gold
cloaks and when he installed bran that
character is actually part of the Nights
Watch now so there's going to be some
friction between him and John remember
none of those people knew about Jon
Snow's mission to infiltrate the
wildlings so everyone really thinks he's
a traitor so there's gonna be a lot of
haters gonna hate it also goes into what
happens with the wildlings if you
remember Jon Snow was getting ready to
march on the Nights Watch there's
actually one new wildling character to
the show he's not new to the story but
we haven't seen him on the show yet it's
called the Magnar of thenn he's really
just another general and the wildling
army like tormund Giantsbane but those
two characters are so similar that the
producers gave a lot of the Magnar
scenes to tormund Giantsbane just so
that they wouldn't have to cast him
early that problem of the producers
having to condense characters and
stories to save space and time is only
gonna get worse book four actually gets
progressively longer than book three so
there's gonna be a ton of stuff that we
probably won't get to see and that
includes Dany in Mereen I'll talk about
her in a separate video but let's talk
about Arya right now she's actually one
of my favorite characters on the show
you can think of her in the Hound in
season three as being like Big Daddy and
little sister from Bioshock you want to
stay as far away from them as possible
they'll actually be some really good
action scenes in the first couple of
episodes with those two characters just
because I think the show's gonna move
really quickly through Vergara morghulis
coin will come back into play if you
remember in the season finale when she
turned into stabby McGee and she looked
at it really strangely I feel like one
of the really awesome things about her
character is is that a lot of her scenes
that are really violent and dark
actually end up being just a little bit
funny which makes it even funnier
because you feel so bad for laughing
when awful things happen I think it's
mostly just because the actress Maisie
Williams looks so young remember that in
the books Arya is really only about 13
years old so when a character like that
is just so dark it's just a little bit
funny and twisted speaking of women that
you should stay away from you grit
actually comes back with a vengeance
let's just say that when she and Jon get
back together it's really awkward
and when I say awkward remember what she
told
before they climbed the wall don't ever
betray me Jon Snow you're basically
saying that I'm gonna cut your balls off
if you ever turn your back on me what
you did this is definitely not like
running into your ex-girlfriend in a
movie theater and I watch out for those
wildling women
yikes Oh gotcha so I'm going to save all
the supporting characters that I didn't
mention for a future video send me your
questions and I'll try to include them
in the next one be sure to subscribe to
get my part 3 video that'll post on
Monday and it will cover Danny in the
east
you can actually click here to watch my
part 1 video it deals with the
characters at King's Landing you can
click here to get my Game of Thrones
Father's Day video it's actually the
best worst dad's on the game of Thrones
so I give away some funny awards thanks
for watching high fives for season four